m
dans le cadre des actions collectives la
maison départementale de saint-andré a
mis en place avec la mairie de la ville
et l'éducation nationale
un forum alimentation santé la
finalisation d'une année de travail mené
sur l'équilibré alimentaire avec des
classes élémentaires et celle du collège
du secteur hors département et s'est
chargé alors peu avec trois
professionnels de la mairie contrat de
ville et de l'éducation nationale on a
mobilisé les familles on a invité les
parents à participer à des instances qui
se tenait directement dans les
établissements scolaires autour de
différents thèmes et on a axé notre
intervention cette année sur
l'alimentation santé
et bah comment manger de manière
équilibrée pour frieder funten
nutritionniste et parrain de l'événement
il est fondamental de sensibiliser
l'enfant à l' équilibre alimentaire et
de responsabiliser les parents pour
prévenir de l'obésité nous avons
expliqué aux parents trois choses la
première c'est la responsabilité en
matière de l'éducation élémentaire de
l'enfant c'est à dire que ils doivent
bien réalisé qu'un enfant a besoin
d'être nourri quatre fois par jour et
que le petit déjeuner est de la
responsabilité
deuxième chose que leur avoir apporté
c'est l'importance des fruits et légumes
ça veut dire qu'en fait mes parents
doivent réaliser que l'enfant ne le
peuvent pas avoir un repas sans fruits
et légumes et ça dès le petit déjeuner
la troisième chose enfin c'était de les
sensibiliser sur l'activité physique et
la place qu'ils peuvent avoir à
entraîner l'enfant dans une partie
sportive dès l'aube dès le jeune âge des
parents très investis qui tout au long
de l'année ont participé au café des
parents afin d'échanger mais également
de bénéficier de précieux conseils pour
la santé de leur enfant hors
alimentation est pourtant passé mais a
beaucoup d enfants tes problèmes à ses
maux de la france c'est tout cas la
russie et donc c'est pour ça qu'au et
naoufel été réalisés dans le domaine
dentaire de nouvelles santé de domaine
social ici ses moyens des changes avec
les parents
c'est comme ma mère tout au long de la
matinée les élèves ont pu profiter
d'ateliers ludiques mais aussi
d'activités physiques
l'événement s'est achevée par un flash
mob qui a réuni les dix neuf classes
présentes